[Music]
slavic thank you for joining us
of course happy to be here i have
nowhere else to be
are you talking from home now yeah i am
a you know sheltering place and all
right so how has it been the past few
weeks have you all moved online as well
all of the misto and powell to networks
yes yes all of us are working from home
in the last few weeks
and we're being fairly productive i have
to say
um i think most of the mystic folks
are kind of young folks you know don't
have lots of kids and whatnot so
they're like instead of going out in the
evening they're actually coding so the
productivity is pretty decent
wow i have four kids at home right now
so uh
four kids uh interesting kind of uh you
know bouncing
between a they you know the online
school
and and kind of you know just managing
everything is uh
is a bit challenging but we're enjoying
it as well
wow so so what surprised you most over
the past
over the past you know month or so of
moving remotely and
working from home uh
the amount of meetings just increased
that kind of surprised me
i i would i would have assumed that you
know people would kind of
focus on you know just their own work
but they
we actually found that they having like
being connected
because you don't have these
interpersonal connections in the office
it actually helps quite a lot and so we
have like daily stand-ups
and and so on and
you know maybe it's not a compliment but
we hear from some folks who
usually works remote that now they feel
a bit more connected
it means that we need to do more you
know during irregular times but
still now they're actually a bit more
connected you know what one of the
things that i
that i'm noticing in my work is that you
know usually you have the meetings
and you have to give a five-minute
buffer between each one so you can walk
to the next one
all of a sudden you don't have to walk
anywhere you finish so the calendar is
still on default 25 minutes instead of
30.
and then you end up sitting there for
five minutes and just waiting
the whole the whole ship mindset has
shifted yeah yeah we we set all of our
meetings we tried to set them to 45
minutes so we can actually move between
meetings
but now you're right here you have more
15 minutes to make more coffee so
exactly actually that's the other thing
that kind of surprised me i'm drinking
much more coffee
there you go there you go it's right
here right like right next to me so
you know every five minutes i will go
for myself coffee
so slavik you sold two companies the
most recent one
de misto for hundreds of millions to
paul to networks
and we got to meet a few months ago and
and i i fell in love with what you guys
are doing in the way that you're
you're really making the life of of any
company
that cares even a little bit about their
about their cyber security much much
easier
much more automatic and talk to me a
little bit about
how did you even get into cyber security
and
let's start from the army the israeli
army yeah and you're working with
databases
right so i i was in the israeli army
in one of the you know computer units
and
uh i guess before that i was i
i studied in the technion i made what's
called today
and so in the army i was in a computer
unit
and we actually
developed a very distributed uh
system around the oracle database so
this kind of got me started with the
oracle databases
and they i guess
we didn't have so i at least my job
wasn't
very much connected to security but that
was something that i really found
interesting all the time
and since i was in the army i was
a kind of a team leader of
developers and
we had obviously limited roles
uh in our permissions this was the first
time i actually got
a a a
court martialed by by somebody because i
hacked into a system to
elevate privileges to myself to actually
do something that is a
that they you know i was
wanting to do in the system so it was
not for malicious purposes but i didn't
have the relevant permissions it was the
weekend i actually had to get
gain access i didn't get anything by the
way so
my punishment was that i needed to
prepare a cyber security
a presentation to the team that's what
the army yeah
all the punishments are our
presentations to the teams yes
so um so aft after the army i naturally
went
into kind of a large infrastructure
consulting
and database consulting and
that was kind of a my first
kind of thinking around why do we need
security
because we did a very large project
for a sony playstation and that project
was
around the playstation online this was
the playstation 2.
so if i take you back in time like all
the soccer games and
and uh and so on by the way i have my
name there in the
in the credit roll really rugging rights
yeah because i was
the one developing the back-end solution
for that
and the apis for the games and so
at the time i was still in israel and
i was kind of working with the remote
databases
of the sony playstation production yeah
you know i would ssh into the box and
can do whatever selects i
i wanted so i could see tens
of millions of credit cards right there
and nobody knew so i i was like a
contractor from israel
like how do they trust me with that it's
so it was so weird
and i i said oh my god so either i take
this 10 million credit cards sell them
on the black market and
oh my god or for a lot of money or i
should develop some solution for that
so this was my first kind of thinking
around a
security and in particular database
security
and i actually started a company called
centrigo
that did exactly that did activity
monitoring for databases
to to make sure that nothing
is against the policy so the dba is not
accessing you know payrolls or or credit
cards or things like that
and so it's mostly you know both attacks
from outside but also
insider threats type of thing yeah so
it's so it's not
it wasn't just about cyber security was
also about human security
and enforcing privacy regulations
within our organization indeed indeed so
that was a kind of my my idea so
in 2006 i i raised some money from a
benchmark israel that no longer exists
and they
and then this is how we started the
centrigo
and it also kind of taught me a lot
about
the whole startup thing yeah because
i i'm an engineer so my
first instinct is to create a
engineering hard to solve solution
and that startup was all around
very hard to solve problems
because the way you monitor databases is
actually
very hard you need to reverse engineer
the database understand the memory
structures
and then through the memory kind of
understand what's running
so it was reverse engineering of like
oracle sql my
mysql sybase db2 all of those relational
databases
and you know it's not documented so you
have
all over the binary do all the worst
engineering ida pro and all of that oh
my god
wow and that was really challenging
really tough but you know the
go-to-market of that
is even harder because you have to get
the dba and the security guy in the same
room
agreeing on something and it was tough
so
it kind of taught me a life lesson about
you know
engineering and you know heart problems
are interesting
but you need to build something that the
customer actually wants and it's easy to
to kind of sell and and and market
so uh do you think that
the experience in the army when you when
you were get when you had all the
you were sort of like this this root
user
of an oracle database in a very high
sensitive
high impact environment is that a is
that a unique experience that you think
positioned you
to really understand what's happening
and and have that confidence in taking
ownership
over something as complicated as
database security
i think overall the army helps you a lot
by basically giving you a lot of
responsibility at a very early age
right so you get a lot of responsibility
and since you can manage that
responsibility you gain confidence
right and you gain confidence and you
understand hey sure yeah i can do it i
can continue doing it
and and from that perspective definitely
also there's there's kind of a a hacker
mentality in the army
yeah your dog is the background he just
wants the toys
so definitely there's a hacker mentality
in the army
so you try to get by with whatever you
have if you have like a
pin and paper clip and and and i don't
know something
you you managed to do something with it
yeah
and you know that you were you were in
the israeli arms so no i i had a
fantastic experience and i the no the
number of times when we were just told
you know this these are your resources
we're not gonna get anything else just
get it done
that's all you have and you get it done
because
you're in the army and you have and you
have that sense of responsibility that
you're not
you're not working you're serving and
and and when
you have that incentive then all of a
sudden things become much
much easier to to execute so you so you
then
so you join you join the mcafee team
right as a result of the acquisition
and then you go on to create an even
bigger company
de misto right right so i was say
so we actually in central ego we
we went through the 2008 crisis which
kind of reminds me of
yes so i moved to the us
in 2008 july
literally like a week before you know
the entire
economy tanked and
i i like to think i brought you know the
the whole crisis here to the us
and it was a terrible experience and
both in terms of you there's really huge
uncertainty
you know you you're looking at a you're
looking at
your customers yeah all of them
basically just
freeze everything and we were struggling
we were struggling to raise money we
were struggling to sell
uh i had to immediately after i came
here i had to fly back and fire
a lot of the team wow we have enough
money like
they looked at the projections we didn't
have enough money
and that's you know we kind of tried to
raise from here and there it was
unbelievable that also kind of taught me
um you know get enough in your war chest
to make sure that you you can execute
through the bad times as well
and so when the opportunity presented
itself
in 2010 we actually engaged mcafee
and in 2011 we sold the we saw the
company
and which was again because because of
the whole crisis it kind of
breaks your your trajectory so you kind
of have
and down and so uh we didn't we just
said hey somebody's making an offer
let's take it
right and and they have to ask
how is the experience you know coming as
a core engineer
and excited about difficult issues i
mean it's not like you you're going like
sergeant
and it's all about like people here and
all of a sudden you find yourself in a
position where you have to go back to
israel you have to
fire some people who you brought on
board and and
all of a sudden it doesn't matter you're
not an engineer now you're a leader
and you're you're responsible for them
so how do you work through that
it was it was tough you know personally
are obviously very tough
for me but you know even tougher for the
ones that we had to let go
we actually really really tried to act
responsibly
um maintain like payments as much as we
could
we also found for most of those folks we
found
jobs alternative jobs because you know
israel is very well connected so we knew
pretty much everybody
yeah and so but it's hard you know
nobody you know not don't let anybody
tell you it's easy this is like super
hard
we kind of we let go about third of the
team
which is which is quite a lot and all
the rest
took a pay cut as well so it was
a you know but you try to do everything
to survive so it's it's
it's really tough i i like to think we
handled it
a you know correctly because i'm still
friends with a bunch of the folks that
we
we let go uh but they but yeah it's
it's tough and so that kind of also
affected me
moving forward we sold i think the
company a bit
too early but again this is what this
was our kind of
uh being scared of what's happening
around the corner so we sold this in
trigo to mcafee
and then um i stayed with mcafee for for
a while
so i stayed stayed with mcafee like for
four years
trying to both
well okay both do their notes as
you know but they then also make sure
that
you know the team is landed correctly
the the product is
driving and so on uh
but i guess after like two two years
became boring though
so i think like into
2014 we were already kind of looking
around so me
what will become my co-founders in in
the visto
we were already kind of looking around
thinking what we should do
and we again this is like
the first instinct is again trying to
solve a really hard problem
right so uh so i kind of convinced
so my my co-founder rishi who was not
part of the original
centurico team he was actually the one
who
who managed the acquisition of us into
mcafee
so he had an office right next to me the
office next to office
yeah and they we
every morning he would come in and they
we would drink coffee had a small
espresso machine in the office and then
we would start
talking about like what we should do and
how
what we should do next and so on so we
started with this idea
of a creating a
an a like an edr solution like endpoint
detection
response but based on a distributed
database
and the um it's kind of a cross
if if you're familiar with the companies
between carbon black and tanium
so you can do real-time queries
understand what is the situation
but also keep all the historical
knowledge in a very efficient way
so that was kind of the idea and we were
like oh my god
you started reading academic papers
around
peer-to-peer databases and started kind
of developing this interesting
architecture
and in 2015 we had a
rsa conference and we
interviewed a lot of ceciles during the
conference because it's a good time to
meet
obviously yeah i think we
met like between 30 and 40 cecils and we
kind of presented that idea to them
and all of them pretty much unanimously
said
it's a crappy idea we are not interested
in another endpoint
and so we kind of had to stop for a
second
think and say okay
what should we do and so we asked them
so actually asked what are the big
problems that they're facing
and what is the you know what are the
big
pain points and and eventually we kind
of
landed on this idea of what eventually
became the mystery which is
uh kind of
helping the security team
cope with the too many alerts too many
security
tools not enough security people and so
making the process as efficient as
possible and
as consistent as possible so that's a
kind of
the mystery in a very very high level
and so
i i i quit making a
i think it was april 2015
and i kind of started kind of working on
that and then rishi then guy kind of
joined me
wow okay and then you know years go by
and
and it's and you sell it uh for quite a
nice amount to palo to networks and now
you're leading
actually you're leading the demisto
product within palo alto networks right
right right and one of the most i mean i
i i haven't seen too many
too many integrations but from the ones
that i've seen of a company acquiring
another company this is a this is
considered a very successful integration
right right right i think actually palo
alto networks did
i think the the the best thing that you
can do
and in many senses left the team alone
yeah so you kind of maintain
the entire structure of the team and
maintain the same kind of spirit of what
they
got you to this successful state and and
it's up to us kind of the leaders to
look around and say how this is
a kind of merging into the existing
businesses
and definitely from the team perspective
they're still feeling like this sayer
matkal as you said
still feeling like this elite team that
continues to execute and
and do what they what what they're best
at
and we kind of are the ones who kind of
incorporate into the processes
and do all the you know they go to
market
and the the npi process
which is you know all the big company
things that that you need to go through
yeah wow that's slavic that's incredible
i mean i i wish we had more time to also
talk about the cyber security space in
general but
but you have to go back to running a
company and
and you're staying safe and healthy and
with four kids at home
and so before we leave i do need three
words that describe you
oh three words that describe me
uh
he didn't prepare me for that and i
think
i think i'm gonna make a lot of enemies
after all these discussions
i always trip people up i think
um curious
tenacious and i like it
i like tenacious smart i guess
i couldn't agree more slavic thank you
very much
thanks happy to be here